muy buenas noches venidos a la crónica
de economía de france 24 dedicada en
esta oportunidad a conocer el escenario
que se vive en chile de cara a las
elecciones del próximo domingo nos
acompaña por supuesto jorge hurtado
jorge bueno como decía chile está a las
puertas de unas elecciones que se van a
ver de un ambiente muy polarizado verdad
que le espera la economía chilena bueno
los domingos los chilenos van a decidir
su futuro económico y las propuestas son
bastante amplias desde la creación de un
estado del bienestar basado en países
europeos hasta reducir el iva por
ejemplo gabriel boric de izquierda que
por mencionar algunos de los candidatos
sugiere en su plan a asegurar una
pensión mínima de 308 dólares así como
aumentar la cotización mensual desde el
actual 10% del salario al 18% con gran
parte del cargo al empleador otro de los
competidores es josé antonio kast que
apuesta por mantener el modelo
ultraliberal impuesto durante la
dictadura de augusto pinochet su plan de
gobierno busca disminuir la
participación del estado en la economía
así como reducir el impuesto al valor
agregado antes conversamos con
él bergoi en el es economista académico
e investigador chileno sobre que se
espera para la economía tras estas
elecciones y esto respondió
efectivamente el día las encuestas al
menos dicen que en segunda vuelta lo más
probable es que gane el candidato que
está más bien en la izquierda no en la
centroizquierda pero en la izquierda
aunque él tiene un equipo técnico de
integrantes que muchos de ellos si son
de santa izquierda yo los conozco varios
de ellos son incluso socialdemócrata
pero es una generación como te decía más
joven y lo que lo que va a ocurrir si él
es elegido que gabriel boric presidente
muy probablemente es que se va a generar
esta tensión entre por un lado lo que
piden los organismos internacionales lo
que típicamente desde la macroeconomía
están valorados que es la certeza la
estabilidad agregada te ayuda a la
inversión de largo plazo es tan
importante para el crecimiento sostenido
pero al mismo tiempo la necesidad de
hacer cambios profundos para como
decíamos mejorar las dimensiones
sociales en particular la distribución y
eso va a generar ruido va a generar
susto va a generar probablemente una
paralización lo digo que completa pero
durante un tiempo en la inversión de
largo plazo y eso claro va a tener
efectos inmediatos en términos de crecer
menos pero la pregunta si vamos a salir
de esos fortalecidos esa es la gran
incógnita que yo vivía jorge vamos a
hablar ahora de uno de los que fue los
temas centrales en la campaña en materia
económica no de cara a las elecciones
chilenas hablamos de los fondos de
pensión que sucede con eso bueno
santiago allí el sistema es privado y es
señalado por obtener grandes beneficios
y de entregar bajos montos a los
jubilados algo que ha motivado el retiro
de estos fondos ahora mismo se discute
un cuarto retiro que el senado rechazó
recientemente esto comentó a nuestro
invitado respecto a las pensiones
algunos políticos particularmente en el
congreso a portas de una elección han
decidido impulsar una serie de retiros
de los fondos de pensiones que lo único
que están haciendo es justamente reducir
la probabilidad de que podamos a esta
generación darle mejores pensiones hacia
adelante porque sea plata al ser
retirada se utiliza hoy y eso que tuvo
mucho cultivo el año pasado cuando
estaba partiendo la pandemia y por lo
tanto el gobierno tenía muchas
dificultades de llegar producto y viene
la gente y que pudo ser justificado en
el primer retiro terminó 103 retiros e
incluso una discusión de un cuarto
retiro diría que ha dejado casi la mitad
de la gente que está en el sistema de
pensiones sin saldo en sus cuentas
entonces en una línea es por un lado se
entiende la necesidad de reformar
profundamente el sistema y obviamente
obviamente uno piensa que como en los
países más exitosos con un sistema más
mixto con un sistema personal y un
sistema en el estado pero al mismo
tiempo se ha usado lamentablemente esa
discusión para justificar en el contexto
de la pandemia retiros significativos
que lo único que van a hacer es
disminuir las posibilidades de que esta
generación tenga buenas tensiones en el
futuro se sacaron 50.000 millones de
dólares que en el caso de chile en
imagínense ustedes es más o menos del
presupuesto un año completo del estado
así que los montos que salieron fueron
gigantesco igual que recuperarlos en
algún momento y eso ver que hacerlo con
más impuestos ahora jorge una pregunta
clave que surge en este contexto y que
vos vas a ayudar por supuesto a
responder es en qué contexto económico
se dan estas elecciones bueno luego el
consumo motivado por el circulante
inyectado en la economía tras los
retiros de los fondos para el próximo
año los datos no son alentadores en el
tercer trimestre de 2020 la economía
chilena se contrajo un 9,1 por ciento
interanual por la pandemia cuando tenía
las actividades económicas
semiparalizada aunque este año el
producto interno bruto creció un 17% se
estima que el 2022 del pib crecerá sólo
entre el 1.5 y el 2.5 la inflación dobla
la proyección oficial del banco central
y la deuda pública está en el 33 por
ciento graciasjorge por esta crónica
dedicada al escenario económico que vive
chile a nuestra audiencia como siempre
le invitamos a continuar y formándose en
el resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com sigan con nosotros
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]